[Music]
we were out of our minds is John Legend
calling out Kanye West on Twitter
[Music]
on Wednesday the all of me singer
tweeted a series of cryptic messages
writing in part quote
I love that great brilliant artists have
the power to imagine a better future but
artists can't be blind to the truth
adding the defining trait of trumps
campaign and political profile was his
embrace of white supremacy he made it
clear every time he spoke the Grammy
winners tweets are seemingly a response
to West who went on a Twitter spree
Wednesday it's extremely important to me
proclaiming his love for President
Donald Trump calling him quote my
brother do something for my heart on
Thursday West shared this text exchange
between him and legend where the singer
pleads with West quote I hope you'll
reconsider aligning yourself with Trump
you're way too powerful and influential
to endorse who he is and what he stands
for don't let this be part of your
legacy
but the rapper wasn't having it his
response quote you bringing up my fans
or my legacy is a tactic to manipulate
my free thought